When I was growing up,
Nintendo was
the thing,
the original nes console,
Super Mario Legend of Zelda metroid,
Mike Tyson's punch out battle toads.
Then we got into Sega and all things
sonic.
Then Super Nintendo came out and I
played a lot of donkey Kong country,
Aladdin and turtles and time Nintendo.
Sixty four was a revelation Mario,
64 Mario Kart,
the lesser known but still great.
Diddy Kong racing and of course the
masterpiece of masterpieces,
awkward arena of time for many kids.
My generation and after video games were
just a part of growing up.
After school,
I'd go to one of my friend's houses and
we'd play 64 or second saturn for a few
hours,
go outside,
run around,
play some more,
go home.
We played video games because it was
something to do like playing horse in
the driveway or Walpole.
It was just another form of competition.
The pure competition of games,
which is just a way of filling free time
with purpose.
The last console I ever owned was
playstation two and I fell off gaming
when gaming got much more complicated
than the side scrolling that I grew up
with.
If at that time you would've asked me,
can video games be art?
I would have said I'm 13.
What do I know?
My opinion on it now is that those games
were games.
The objectives were clear,
the rules relatively simple like soccer
or basketball or any other sport.
The primary purpose of the experience
was to win in the period.
Since Games have become vastly more
complicated and the question of whether
or not that form is an art of fine art
has become the topic of serious
philosophical debate legally.
Of course,
that decision was decided on much more
specific terms.
It started in the early eighties when a
series of American court decisions found
that video games could not be covered
under arts free speech protections
because they were no more expressive
than pinball or chest.
Those precedents determine much of what
followed in 2002 federal judge Steven
Limbo ruled against the protection of
games.
Saying that like,
Bingo,
the court fails to see how video games
express ideas,
impressions,
feelings,
or information unrelated to the game
itself.
Not until 2011 the matter get the
definitive decision that it deserved
when the Supreme Court finally extended
arts protections to video games in Brown
vs the entertainment Merchants
Association in a seven to two rule,
and of course the legal definition of
video game stands quite apart from their
philosophical definition,
but in the time span of all those little
decisions,
the scope of video games has expanded to
include things like missed grand theft
auto,
the Sims,
rpgs with narratives more compelling
than most science fiction in Hollywood
or contemporary literature.
Games today have real and fully realized
economies like the one which was shaken
to its core in eve online when this mega
space battle from earlier this year
destroyed endgame spaceships to the of
300,000
real dollars and visually.
I don't know if you can get more
digitally sophisticated than the
cinematics for games like Batman Arkham
asylum or elder scrolls.
I don't know if you can find an
experience more elegant than the
Gameplay for Super Mario Galaxy or feds.
Do.
All of these things complex as they are
at up to art.
Well,
at the core of this is the question of
whether something that must be
categorized as a game can also be
categorized as a work of art to be sure
all kinds of artistic expression involve
some interaction with the source
material,
but is the physical interaction in
gaming of some kind of qualitatively
disqualifying kind?
I've always been a stickler for
distinctions for philosophical labels,
but it's questions like this that make
me think about why people are very
precious about art and they try to
include all the things they love under
its masthead like advertising or
cooking,
but to me the desperate attempt to have
games included in the art speaks less to
the significance of the category of art.
Then the curious lack of significance.
We attach in comparison to the category
of games.
The extraordinary injection of subtlety
and beauty into the universe of video
games seems to me a herald of what
gaming can and will be to us in the
future.
In the 2012 game called journey,
you play as a rope to figure in the
desert,
moving slowly,
gracefully wordlessly toward a shining
mountains in the distance.
The goal is singular,
but gradually informed by traces on the
faded civilization.
Then you discover along the way the game
play the music,
the symbolism of the culture that was
lost puts you in an emotional space,
unique to all other forms of media.
Reaching the mountain is like an
apotheosis and like the apotheosis of
art.
It is the kind that life itself is it
capable of sustaining.
Contained in this game is a meditation
both on the unspoiled image of what we
want and it's profound unsatisfactories
reflection,
what we thought.
Fuck yeah.
For Video Games,
thanks for watching and allowing a sort
of non game or to take part in this
really fascinating discussion.
I still do play Mario Cart on a regular
basis,
so that should give me something.
If you liked this video,
please share it on reddit.
That's just been the best way to get
these videos out there and follow me on
twitter and Tumbler and asked me
anything you want in the comments and I
will reply to you.
I'll see you next Friday.